So we have a new president. But after the recount mess in Florida this fall and the Supreme Court decision that ended the election, some people are having a hard time moving on. Why? Why can't they just let it go? Eric Potter drove to the inauguration to protest with his wife and kids, though he has never protested anything before.
我们有了一位新总统。但在今年秋天佛罗里达州重新计票的混乱以及最高法院结束选举的裁决之后，有些人很难走出阴影。为什么？他们为什么不能放下这件事？埃里克·波特（Eric Potter）带着妻子和孩子开车去参加就职典礼进行抗议，尽管他以前从未抗议过任何事情。
Never before.
以前从未有过。
And what about this is different?
这件事有什么不同之处呢？
The Constitution has been subverted and people don't seem to care.
宪法被颠覆了，而人们似乎并不在意。
Were you Gore supporters during the election?
你们在选举期间是戈尔的支持者吗？
Not strongly.
不算特别坚定。
Are you still mad?
你们还在生气吗？
Extremely. If he's the rightful winner, I don't have a problem with him in the White House. But I don't believe he's the rightful winner, and we will never know that. We should count all the votes, and that hasn't happened yet.
非常生气。如果他是合法的获胜者，我对他入主白宫没有意见。但我不相信他是合法的获胜者，而且我们永远也不会知道真相。我们应该清点所有的选票，但那还没有发生。
Republicans simply do not understand this. They think the Democrats were being divisive and unreasonable during the recounts and it's just galling that they won't let it go now.
共和党人根本不理解这一点。他们认为民主党人在重新计票期间表现得分裂且不合理，现在他们不愿罢休，真是让人恼火。
Get over it. I mean, there's nothing that they can do. Get over it.
算了吧。我是说，他们什么也做不了。算了吧。
Do you think there's any fair basis to anything they're saying about the Florida recounts?
你认为他们关于佛罗里达州重新计票的说法有任何公平的依据吗？
No, it was such a farce, the whole thing was. Counting, recounting, counting, recounting. We could have gone and recounted all of the United States. And states that Bush just barely lost, we could have gone and recounted those.
不，那简直是一场闹剧，整个过程都是。计票、重计、再计、再重计。我们可以去把全美所有的选票都重新计一遍。布什以微弱优势落败的那些州，我们本可以去重新计票的。
There have always been people at the extremes of the political parties who are really bitter, who are just furious at the other side. But as this election dragged on for weeks this fall, it seemed like more and more people got caught up in those kinds of feelings. And now where are those feelings supposed to go?
政党极端派中总有一些人非常愤世嫉俗，对另一方感到无比愤怒。但随着今年秋天这场选举持续数周之久，似乎越来越多的人被卷入了这种情绪中。现在，这些情绪该何去何从呢？
On inauguration day, 40% of Americans still thought that George Bush had not been legitimately elected as president. That's a lot of people. I think they're so divisive that even saying it's a lot of people out loud is seen as divisive. When I interviewed Democrats, the thing that most of them say is that it's not that they want to throw George Bush out of office at this point. Feelings do not run that high. It's more like they still have these moments of surprise when they happen to see him in the newspaper or on television. Like, right. He's President. It's real.
在就职典礼当天，仍有40%的美国人认为乔治·布什并非合法当选总统。那是很多人。我认为他们太分裂了，以至于连说出“很多人”这个事实本身都被视为一种分裂行为。当我采访民主党人时，他们大多数人说，并不是说他们现在想把乔治·布什赶下台。情绪还没有那么激动。更多的情况是，当他们在报纸或电视上偶然看到他时，仍会感到惊讶。就像是，没错。他是总统。这是真的。
On the other side, a Republican named Chris Robling, a former election commissioner here in Chicago, says that since Florida, he feels a little chill between him and his Democrat friends. Democrats can be so arrogant when it comes to Republicans. They can look down on them, and it's only gotten worse. He took a tape recorder and talked to his friend Kathleen about it.
另一方面，一位名叫克里斯·罗布林（Chris Robling）的共和党人，也就是芝加哥的前选举委员，他说自从佛罗里达事件以来，他感觉到自己和民主党朋友之间产生了一丝隔阂。民主党人在面对共和党人时会非常傲慢。他们会瞧不起对方，而这种情况只会变得更糟。他拿着录音机和他的朋友凯瑟琳（Kathleen）谈论了这件事。
How does this affect your view of somebody like me? That I'm a Republican and that I was for this guy and that I was for what happened in Florida?
这如何影响你对像我这样的人的看法？我是共和党人，我支持这个人，并且我支持佛罗里达州发生的事情？
You told me you weren't for what happened in Florida, you said you were ashamed of how he got elected.
你告诉过我你并不支持佛罗里达州发生的事情，你说你为他当选的方式感到羞愧。
I'm for the fact that he ultimately won.
我支持他最终获胜这一事实。
Of course you are. Republicans were for power at all costs. That's a creepy, nasty, vicious attitude.
你当然支持。共和党人不惜一切代价追求权力。这是一种令人毛骨悚然、卑鄙且恶毒的态度。
So am I creepy, nasty, and vicious?
那么，我是令人毛骨悚然、卑鄙且恶毒的吗？
Yes. I have thought that about you since I found out you were really a Republican. Yeah, there's a really creepy side to you. There is, I'm sorry. I'll probably have fewer and fewer Republican friends because I don't seem to be able to get over it.
是的。自从我发现你真的是共和党人以来，我就一直这么看你。是的，你确实有令人毛骨悚然的一面。真的有，我很抱歉。我可能会越来越少有共和党朋友，因为我似乎无法摆脱这种情绪。
From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our radio program, moving on after the election. Democrats trying to, Republicans urging them to. Urging them with such vehemence that you get the feeling that they're not entirely over the Florida debacle either. Our show today in five acts.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台的《这就是美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天在我们的广播节目中，我们谈论选举后的继续前进。民主党人试图放下，共和党人敦促他们放下。他们敦促得如此激烈，以至于让你觉得他们自己也没有完全从佛罗里达州的惨败中走出来。我们今天的节目分为五个部分。
Act One, You're Not the President of Me, in which we examine the non-intersecting realities of the two sides in the political spectrum right now. Act Two, a Brief History of Republican Time. Writer David Brock gives us the inside story of how we got to this point of bitterness exactly. And it is not pretty, my friends.
第一幕，“你不是我的总统”，我们将审视目前政治光谱双方互不交集的现实。第二幕，“共和党时间的简史”。作家大卫·布洛克（David Brock）为我们讲述了我们究竟是如何走到今天这种苦涩地步的内幕故事。而且，我的朋友们，这并不光彩。
Act Three, Bedroom Politics, in which a happily married couple suddenly gets politics-- different politics-- making it hard for them to move on now. Act Four, Let Us Reason Together, in which we try to get each side to understand the other in the Supreme Court Case Bush v. Gore.
第三幕，“卧室政治”，一对幸福的已婚夫妇突然陷入了政治——不同的政治立场——导致他们现在很难释怀。第四幕，“让我们共同论证”，我们将尝试让每一方理解对方在最高法院布什诉戈尔案中的立场。
Act Five, What Would You Know Who Do? A chat with an African-American minister in Florida who is trying not to be mad about the election because it is against his religion. Stay with us.
第五幕，“你猜是谁会怎么做？”，与佛罗里达州一位非裔美国牧师的聊天，他正努力不去对选举感到愤怒，因为这违背了他的信仰。请继续收听。
Act One, You're Not the President of Me. Back when president Clinton was being impeached, at least Republicans and Democrats agreed on the basic facts-- he fooled around with an intern and he lied about it. The only dispute was over whether this was an important violation of the law. In Florida-- and who thought it would ever be possible for anyone to say this-- in Florida, things were much more bitter. Partly because the two sides did not even agree on the basic facts of what was happening. It was two entirely different pictures of the world with very little overlap.
第一幕，“你不是我的总统”。当克林顿总统面临弹劾时，至少共和党人和民主党人在基本事实上达成了共识——他与实习生有染并对此撒了谎。唯一的争议在于这是否构成对法律的重大违背。而在佛罗里达——谁能想到有人会说出这样的话——在佛罗里达，情况要痛苦得多。部分原因是双方甚至无法就正在发生的基本事实达成一致。这是两幅截然不同的世界图景，几乎没有交集。
Here is Jonathan Chait of The New Republic , a self-described liberal, telling the story of the recount with David Horowitz of Salon Magazine , a self-described conservative. Jonathan Chait starts.
这里是《新共和》（The New Republic）的乔纳森·查特（Jonathan Chait），自称是自由派，他与自称保守派的《沙龙》（Salon）杂志的大卫·霍洛维茨（David Horowitz）讲述了重新计票的故事。由乔纳森·查特开始。
Statistically, you can prove without a doubt that Al Gore would have won Florida if it were not for faulty machines. Now from there, you can argue--
从统计学上讲，你可以毫无疑问地证明，如果不是因为机器故障，阿尔·戈尔会赢得佛罗里达州。现在从那里开始，你可以争辩——
Wait wait wait, how can you do that?
等等，等等，你怎么能这么做？
Well, there are several ways to do it. The best is the way the Miami Herald did it, which is they did a precinct-by-precinct analysis and simply looked at how many non-votes there were in each precinct. And then they found that Gore would have won by 20,000 votes.
好吧，有几种方法可以做到。最好的方法是《迈阿密先驱报》所采用的方法，即他们进行了逐个选区的分析，仅仅观察每个选区有多少未计票。然后他们发现戈尔会多赢20,000张选票。
So for each precinct you say OK, all these people whose votes we do know, they split this way. This many for Gore, this many for Bush. Let's just ascribe to the uncounted ballots the same proportions, and then you get your number.
所以对于每个选区，你说好的，这些我们已经知道投向的选票，它们是这样分配的。这么多投给戈尔，这么多投给布什。让我们把同样的比例赋予那些未统计的选票，然后你就会得到你的数字。
That's exactly right. So if you do that, you know that Gore wins. And this is indisputable. This is statistically as sound as anything can be.
完全正确。所以如果你这样做，你就知道戈尔赢了。这是无可争辩的。在统计学上这就像任何事情一样严谨。
The only reason that there's this big hoopla on the left is because Al Gore set out to steal the election after it was over. There's this line about, let's count every vote. Al Gore didn't want to count every vote. What about the Republican counties in Florida? There were six times as many as there were Democratic counties that didn't get their votes counted.
左派之所以大肆喧哗，唯一的原因是阿尔·戈尔在选举结束后试图窃取胜利。有一句话说，让我们清点每一张选票。阿尔·戈尔并不想清点每一张选票。佛罗里达州的共和党县呢？那里没有被清点选票的县是民主党县的六倍多。
By focusing on four counties in Florida, which are overwhelmingly Democratic, where Democrats controlled the judging process and the whole process, that's just a prescription. A prescription for a kind of civil war. Because what could Republicans do? They had to stop the Democrats from manufacturing a vote.
通过关注佛罗里达州的四个县，这些县绝大多数是民主党人，民主党人控制了评判过程和整个流程，这简直就是一张处方。一张导致某种内战的处方。因为共和党人能做什么？他们必须阻止民主党人伪造选票。
If you acknowledge that Gore would have won if it were not for faulty voting machines which, again, is indisputable, then the worst thing you could say about Gore is that he's trying to steal what was already rightfully his. Now, it may be the case that the physical evidence for resolving that problem in Florida is not strong enough. It may be the case that dimpled chads aren't clear enough marks of a voter's intent.
如果你承认如果不是因为投票机故障，戈尔本会获胜——这再次是无可争辩的——那么关于戈尔你能说的最坏的话就是他试图窃取本应属于他的东西。现在，解决佛罗里达州那个问题的实物证据可能不够充分。可能凹陷的选票戳孔（dimpled chads）不足以清晰表明选民的意图。
But I guess I would have two answers to that. First of all, you might as well try. Number two, anyone who's actually seen a ballot in Florida-- which I have-- would, I think, conclude that a dimpled chad is an attempt at a vote. We've had a few these ballots floating around our office and we've tried to play with them. And none of us has been able to create a dimpled chad unless there's something blocking the ballot.
但我猜我有两个答案。首先，你最好试一试。第二，任何真正见过佛罗里达州选票的人——我见过——我认为都会得出结论，凹陷的选票戳孔是选民尝试投票的结果。我们的办公室里放着几张这样的选票，我们试着摆弄过它们。除非有什么东西挡住了选票，否则我们谁也没法制造出一个凹陷的戳孔。
Now the reason that's important, people might forget, is that the democratic theory of why you have dimpled ballots is that something blocks the ballot. Either it's misaligned in the machine or all the chads that fell through in the machine built up to the point where it's blocking the hole and you can't punch the chad cleanly through because something's behind it.
现在这之所以重要，人们可能会忘记，关于为什么会有凹陷选票的民主理论是，有什么东西挡住了选票。要么是机器里的位置对齐不准，要么是机器里掉下来的所有选票戳孔堆积到了挡住孔洞的地步，导致你没法干净利落地把戳孔打穿，因为背后有东西挡着。
The Republican theory is that voters were putting their stylus down on the Gore hole and then changing their mind by the thousands. But if you look at one of these ballots, you realize it really can't be done. If you're able to punch through, you can't create a dimple. So the fact of the dimple being there is evidence of an inability to punch through to the chad.
共和党的理论是，选民们把触针放在戈尔的孔洞上，然后成千上万地改变了主意。但如果你看一看这些选票，你就会意识到这真的做不到。如果你能打穿，你就没法制造出一个凹陷。所以凹陷存在的事实证明了无法将戳孔打穿。
When the votes were counted, these people bent the ballots, popped the chads, and they just attempted it in front of the whole nation and it didn't work.
当选票被清点时，这些人弯曲了选票，弹出了戳孔，他们在全国人民面前尝试了，但没有成功。
Do you think there could have been a way to get a fair count of these dimpled chads?
你认为有没有可能对这些凹陷的选票进行公平的计票？
No. The only fair account is the machine count with all its unfairnesses, if that's not too paradoxical. Machines, so they make mistakes, it tends to be distributed evenly or, at least, blindly. There's no way to hand count and make it fair, because it's subjective.
不。唯一的公平统计是机器计票，尽管它有各种不公平之处，如果这听起来不那么矛盾的话。机器会犯错，但往往是均匀分布的，或者至少是盲目地分布。没有办法通过手工计票来做到公平，因为它是主观的。
Well, I think people should just let it go. The election is over. You can't, in a country of 300 million people, adjudicate this ad infinitum. You just can't run a country that way. There is no actual count. That's what people have to understand.
好吧，我认为人们应该放下它。选举结束了。在一个拥有3亿人口的国家，你不能无限期地裁决这个问题。你不能那样治理国家。根本不存在所谓的真实计票。这就是人们必须明白的。
I really think this is the worst thing I've ever seen happen in politics, as long as I've been following it. I guess I regard Bush as illegitimate. I think about it every time Bush says something like, even though I won by a narrow margin. Well what if you lost? What if it was a negative 500,000 margin?
我真的认为这是我关注政治以来见过的最糟糕的事情。我想我视布什为非法。每当布什说出类似“尽管我以微弱优势获胜”的话时，我都会想到这一点。好吧，如果你输了呢？如果差距是负的50万呢？
Stop with the saying this is an illegitimate president. He got 49 million votes or something. It was a very close election, it could have gone either way. And start participating in a constructive process to bring the sides together.
别再说这是一个非法总统了。他获得了4900万张选票什么的。这是一场非常接近的选举，结果可能倒向任何一方。开始参与一个建设性的进程来团结各方吧。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: David Horowitz, his new book is called The Art of Political War , and Jonathan Chait of The New Republic .
（主持人）艾拉·格拉斯：大卫·霍洛维茨，他的新书名为《政治战争的艺术》（The Art of Political War），以及《新共和》的乔纳森·查特。
Hearing them side by side reminds me of a conversation I had at the inauguration last week with a World War II vet, a Republican donor from Michigan named Robert Brown, who I ran into right by the reviewing stands at the White House.
听着他们并排争论，让我想起上周在就职典礼上我和一位二战老兵的谈话，他是一位来自密歇根州的共和党捐款人，名叫罗伯特·布朗（Robert Brown），我在白宫的检阅台旁碰到了他。
So you don't understand their arguments at all?
所以你完全不理解他们的论点？
No, I don't understand them at all. I don't think they were valid at all. I'm sure they wonder, as I wonder, I wonder what goes through their mind to think as they do, and they wonder what goes through my mind.
不，我完全不理解。我认为它们一点也不成立。我肯定他们也像我一样好奇，我想知道他们脑子里在想什么，而他们也想知道我脑子里在想什么。
Do you think politics are getting more bitter?
你认为政治变得越来越苦涩了吗？
Oh yes. Terribly so.
噢，是的。非常苦涩。
And is that a bad thing? Is that worrisome?
这是一件坏事吗？这令人担忧吗？
Very worrisome to me. I don't know where it's going to end. Fortunately, I don't have to see too much more of it. You do. You'll have to see a lot of it.
对我来说非常令人担忧。我不知道这会走向何方。幸运的是，我不必再看到太多了。你还得看。你还得看很多。
Now there's a reassuring thought.
那真是一个令人安心的想法。
And maybe you can learn to live with it. I'm not sure I can learn to live with it. But I guess every cloud has a silver lining. And at my age, I don't have to live with it too much longer.
也许你能学会忍受它。我不确定我是否能学会忍受。但我猜每一片乌云都有一线希望。而在我这个年纪，我不必再忍受太久了。
That's right. The one comfort in dying someday is knowing you never have to watch Crossfire again.
没错。总有一天会死带来的唯一慰藉就是知道你再也不用看《交叉火力》（Crossfire）节目了。
Indeed it is, Act Two, A Brief History of Republican Time. So how did we get to this point where politics is so bitter? David Brock has a particular view of this. He used to be a right-wing journalistic hitman. First, he wrote an investigative book about Anita Hill. Then he was the very first reporter to mention Paula Jones by name in a story, which led, you could say, to her going public and suing Clinton, which led to him lying in a deposition-- lies which later became grounds for his impeachment. Brock published an apology to Clinton. He is uniquely situated to give a first-hand history of recent politics.
确实如此，第二幕，“共和党时间的简史”。那么我们是如何走到政治如此苦涩的地步的呢？大卫·布洛克有独特的看法。他曾经是右翼新闻界的“杀手”。首先，他写了一本关于安妮塔·希尔（Anita Hill）的调查书。然后，他是第一个在报道中提到保拉·琼斯（Paula Jones）名字的记者，这可以说是促使她公开并起诉克林顿的原因，这又导致了他在证词中撒谎——这些谎言后来成为了弹劾他的理由。布洛克向克林顿发表了道歉声明。他处于一个独特的地位，可以提供第一手近期政治史。
The vein-popping conservative backlash Americans witnessed after the 2000 election is rooted in the war over judicial nominees that began in the late 1980s when Presidents Reagan and Bush tried to roll back decades of socially progressive court decisions by confirming conservative judges to the bench. In Republican eyes, the Robert Bork nomination was the same as the Clarence Thomas hearings. Attacks, lies and misrepresentations. They vowed revenge. Newt Gingrich was in on the tone-setting war from the start. Writing shortly after Bork's defeat, he promised to fight the Democrats quote, "with the scale and duration and savagery that is true only of civil wars."
美国人在2000年大选后目睹的那场令人愤怒的保守派反弹，其根源在于80年代末开始的针对司法提名人的战争，当时里根总统和布什总统试图通过确认保守派法官进入法院，来扭转几十年来社会进步的法院裁决。在共和党人眼中，罗伯特·博克（Robert Bork）的提名和克拉伦斯·托马斯（Clarence Thomas）的听证会是一回事。攻击、谎言和虚假陈述。他们发誓要复仇。纽特·金里奇（Newt Gingrich）从一开始就参与了这场定下基调的战争。他在博克失败后不久写道，他承诺要“以只有内战才有的规模、持续时间和野蛮程度”与民主党人作战。
Gingrich and the people around him were not conservatives in the original sense of the word. They were radicals who consciously adopted the street fighting political style of the '60s for their own ends. In the early '90s, Gingrich's posse hung out at the Capitol Hill row house of Grover Norquist, an anti-tax lobbyist whom The New Republic once called the Che Guevara of the Republican revolution.
金里奇和他周围的人并不是传统意义上的保守派。他们是激进分子，为了自己的目的，有意识地采用了60年代街头政治的斗争风格。在90年代初，金里奇的一伙人经常在格罗弗·诺奎斯特（Grover Norquist）的国会山联排别墅聚会，诺奎斯特是一位反税收游说者，《新共和》曾称他为共和革命的切·格瓦拉。
At Norquist parties, where conservatives convene to drink kegs and grouse about the latest liberal outrages, I ran into former Reagan and Bush speechwriter Peggy Noonan, Weekly Standard editor William Kristol, conservative pundit Laura Ingraham, Wall Street Journal editorial writer John Fund, and many of the figures you saw kicking and screaming on TV about the stolen election.
在诺奎斯特的派对上，保守派聚集在一起喝桶装啤酒，抱怨最新的自由派暴行，我遇到了前里根和布什演讲稿撰写人佩吉·努南（Peggy Noonan）、《标准周刊》（Weekly Standard）编辑威廉·克里斯托（William Kristol）、保守派评论员劳拉·英格拉汉姆（Laura Ingraham）、《华尔街日报》编辑约翰·丰德（John Fund），以及许多你在电视上看到为“窃取选举”而大喊大叫的人物。
The integrity of ballots was the last thing I ever thought this crowd would get worked up over. Norquist kept a pet boa constrictor named Lysander Spooner, after a turn-of-the-century anarchist. A majestic portrait of Lenin graced Norquist's living room wall. Incongruously for such a right wing crowd, Peter Paul and Mary tunes played on the stereo. I asked Norquist about this once and he told me it was OK, since the '60s left wing was being destroyed.
选票的完整性是我认为这群人会为此大动干戈的最后一件事。诺奎斯特养了一条宠物蟒蛇，名叫莱桑德·斯普纳（Lysander Spooner），以一位世纪之交的无政府主义者命名。列宁的一幅宏伟肖像悬挂在诺奎斯特的客厅墙上。对于这样一个右翼群体来说，客厅里播放着彼得、保罗和玛丽（Peter, Paul and Mary）的音乐，这显得很不协调。我曾问过诺奎斯特这个问题，他告诉我没关系，因为60年代的左翼已经被摧毁了。
After the Cold War, Gingrich and company candidly recognized that the Cold War's demonizing, us-versus-them worldview could still be useful. They just turned it against their domestic enemy. Now it was the Democrats they called unprincipled, immoral, and un-American. The shift from one enemy to another culminated at the Republican National Convention in 1992 in Houston, where RNC Chairman Rich Bond stood on the convention floor and said, of the Clintons and their supporters, we are America. Those other people are not.
冷战结束后，金里奇和他的同伴们坦率地认识到，冷战时期妖魔化的“我们对抗他们”的世界观仍然是有用的。他们只是把它转向了国内的敌人。现在，他们称民主党人为无原则、不道德和不爱国。从一个敌人到另一个敌人的转变在1992年休斯顿举行的共和党全国代表大会上达到了顶峰，当时共和党全国委员会主席里奇·邦德（Rich Bond）站在大会现场说，关于克林顿夫妇和他们的支持者，“我们就是美国。其他人则不是。”
Republicans have never forgotten that in 1992, the ballots cast for Ross Perot combined with those cast for George Bush constituted a majority of the electorate. In their minds, the will of the people clearly favored conservative leadership. On election night in 1992, then-Senate Minority Leader Bob Dole went on national television and denounced the Clinton-Gore ticket, which had won with 43% of the vote, as illegitimate.
共和党人永远不会忘记，1992年投给罗斯·佩罗（Ross Perot）的选票加上投给乔治·布什的选票构成了选民的多数。在他们看来，人民的意志显然倾向于保守派领导。1992年选举之夜，时任参议院少数党领袖鲍勃·多尔（Bob Dole）在全国电视上发表讲话，谴责以43%选票获胜的克林顿-戈尔竞选组合是非法的。
That made it possible to say and do anything to stop them. And boy, did we try. The American Spectator, for example, spent $2.4 million looking for dirt on the Clintons, including sending me to Arkansas to chase down outlandish stories linking Clinton to drug running and murder. I'd come back telling them the stories weren't true. They'd figure out a way to publish them anyway.
这使得说出和做出任何事情来阻止他们都成为了可能。天哪，我们确实尝试了。例如，《美国旁观者》（American Spectator）花费了240万美元挖掘克林顿夫妇的黑料，包括派我到阿肯色州去追踪那些将克林顿与贩毒和谋杀联系在一起的荒谬故事。我回来告诉他们这些故事不真实。他们还是会想办法把它们刊登出来。
Riding a wave of anti-Clinton sentiment, the Gingrich revolution swept into power in 1994. In came a generation of right-wing rabble-rousers whose politics seemed based as much on raw emotion and invective as conservative ideals. The radical right wasn't pretending to be outraged at Clinton for dramatic effect; the rage was real, even when they knew they were stretching the facts to make their case. Beginning with the famous election night party that Laura Ingraham and I threw to celebrate the 1994 election, my house in Georgetown became the center of social life for the revolution.
乘着反克林顿情绪的浪潮，金里奇革命在1994年掌权。一群右翼煽动者登上政治舞台，他们的政治似乎像保守派理想一样，建立在原始情绪和谩骂之上。激进右翼并不是为了戏剧效果而假装对克林顿愤怒；即使他们知道自己在扭曲事实以支持自己的观点时，愤怒也是真实的。从劳拉·英格拉汉姆和我为庆祝1994年选举而举办的著名选举之夜派对开始，我在乔治城的家就成了革命的社交中心。
The highlight of my dinner parties was always a dramatic reading from Gennifer Flowers's steamy book, Passion and Betrayal. Here's a typical passage.
我晚餐派对的亮点总是朗读詹妮弗·弗劳尔斯（Gennifer Flowers）香艳书籍《激情与背叛》（Passion and Betrayal）中的片段。这是一段典型的段落。
"Yes, I found Bill Clinton incredibly sexy. I can still remember the way he had of staring at me. He did more than just mentally undress me. He was visually seducing me, and he made sure I knew it."
“是的，我发现比尔·克林顿令人难以置信的性感。我仍然记得他盯着我看的方式。他不仅仅是在心理上剥光我的衣服。他在视觉上诱惑我，并且他确保我知道这一点。”
When Gingrich's extreme anti-government agenda fell flat, furious Republicans fought back. GOP congressional investigation staffers, together with friends of mine who worked for Kenneth Starr, quickly generated charges, counter-charges, conspiracy theories, and rumors designed to depict the Clintons as criminals. After I introduced Paula Jones to the world in the pages of the American Spectator , I was one of the right wing's golden boys and I was in the thick of it all. We were on a mission.
当金里奇极端的反政府议程落空时，愤怒的共和党人进行了反击。共和党国会调查工作人员，连同我在肯尼斯·斯塔尔（Kenneth Starr）手下工作的朋友们，迅速制造了指控、反指控、阴谋论和谣言，旨在将克林顿夫妇描述为罪犯。在我在《美国旁观者》的版面上向世界介绍保拉·琼斯之后，我成为了右翼的宠儿之一，我身处这一切的中心。我们肩负着使命。
Among Clinton's foes, tempers boiled over as the promised indictments failed to materialize and Clinton won reelection handily. Tired of running down dead ends, I bailed out soon afterward. But the right never stopped believing that the Clinton-Gore administration was a depraved, criminal syndicate.
在克林顿的敌人中，当承诺的起诉未能实现且克林顿轻松连任时，人们的脾气爆发了。厌倦了走进死胡同，我不久后就退出了。但右翼从未停止相信克林顿-戈尔政府是一个堕落的犯罪集团。
In the fall of 1997, months before the Monica Lewinsky scandal broke, I attended a dinner given by the American Spectator . The subject of discussion that evening was how to build support for an impeachment resolution, introduced by representative Bob Barr of Georgia. John Fund from the Wall Street Journal said it was quote, "not a matter of law but of political will."
1997年秋天，在莫妮卡·莱温斯基（Monica Lewinsky）丑闻爆发前几个月，我参加了由《美国旁观者》举办的一场晚宴。那天晚上的讨论主题是如何为乔治亚州众议员鲍勃·巴尔（Bob Barr）提出的弹劾决议争取支持。《华尔街日报》的约翰·丰德说，这“不是法律问题，而是政治意愿问题”。
The Republicans saw their subsequent failure to remove Clinton from office as a historic defeat, but they didn't blame themselves. In their minds, they had simply been outmaneuvered by the oily Clinton-Gore spin machine, tricky lawyers, and the liberal-leaning media. And they would do everything they could to ensure that nothing like this ever happened again.
共和党人将他们随后的罢免克林顿失败视为一次历史性挫折，但他们并没有责怪自己。在他们看来，他们只是被圆滑的克林顿-戈尔宣传机器、诡计多端的律师和偏向自由派的媒体所玩弄。他们将尽一切努力确保不再发生这样的事情。
This is the political backdrop for Florida's recent drama. And it explains why Republicans so quickly concluded that Florida Democrats were colluding with Gore to steal the election, and why they were so adamant about drawing their line in the sand. It also explains why, during the recount, polls showed that 75% of Democrats would have accepted Bush as president, but barely 60% of Republicans would accept Gore.
这就是佛罗里达州最近戏剧性事件的政治背景。这也解释了为什么共和党人如此迅速地断定佛罗里达州的民主党人正与戈尔勾结以窃取选举，以及为什么他们如此坚持要划定底线。这也解释了为什么在重新计票期间，民意调查显示75%的民主党人会接受布什为总统，但只有不到60%的共和党人会接受戈尔。
During the disputed recount and in the months since, when the mainstream press talks about what happened in Florida, the story it tells, the story that's become the accepted version of events, is that the Democrats and Republicans behave the same as each other. That their actions were morally equivalent. I don't think that's true. Inside the courts, they might have fought with equal fierceness and self-interest, but outside the courtroom Bush and his allies showed a willingness to rely on rhetoric and tactics that the Democrats didn't.
在争议性的重新计票期间以及随后的几个月里，当主流媒体谈论佛罗里达发生了什么时，它讲述的故事，那个已经成为公认事实的故事，是民主党人和共和党人的表现如出一辙。他们的行为在道德上是等同的。我不认为这是真的。在法庭内，他们可能以同等的激烈程度和自身利益进行斗争，但在法庭外，布什及其盟友表现出了一种依赖民主党人所没有的修辞和策略的意愿。
Bush's top strategist, former Secretary of State James Baker, portrayed court decisions that went against Bush as partisan and illegitimate. Republicans charged that Gore could not pull ahead without cheating and stealing. House Majority Whip Tom DeLay decried a theft in process and George Will referred to slow motion larceny. Republican morality czar William Bennett said a Gore victory in Florida would be illegitimate. Former Senator Bob Dole suggested that Republicans might boycott a Gore inaugural.
布什的首席战略家、前国务卿詹姆斯·贝克（James Baker）将不利于布什的法院裁决描绘成有党派偏见且非法的。共和党人指责戈尔不作弊和偷窃就无法领先。众议院多数党党鞭汤姆·迪莱（Tom DeLay）谴责这是一场“正在进行的盗窃”，乔治·威尔（George Will）称之为“慢动作盗窃”。共和党道德沙皇威廉·班尼特（William Bennett）表示，戈尔在佛罗里达州的胜利将是非法的。前参议员鲍勃·多尔建议共和党人可能抵制戈尔的就职典礼。
During the controversy over military ballots, Bush spokesman Marc Racicot, the governor of Montana, all but called the Gore forces unpatriotic, saying that they had gone to war against the men and women who serve in our armed forces. There's no equivalent on the Democratic side to all this. The Gore team was under orders not to attack the Republicans or impugn the integrity of the judicial process. When Gore spokesman Chris LeHane did otherwise and called Katherine Harris commissar, the Gore staff was ordered not to let it happen again.
在关于军事选票的争议中，布什发言人、蒙大拿州州长马克·拉西科特（Marc Racicot）几乎称戈尔阵营是不爱国的，说他们已经向在武装部队中服役的男女军人宣战。在民主党这边，没有任何与之对等的言论。戈尔团队有指令不得攻击共和党人或质疑司法程序的完整性。当戈尔发言人克里斯·勒汉（Chris LeHane）反其道而行之，称凯瑟琳·哈里斯（Katherine Harris）为“政委”时，戈尔的工作人员被要求不得让此类事件再次发生。
Perhaps most disturbing were reports of Republican violence. Democratic officials in Florida said they were kicked, chased, and shouted down by Republican protesters. In Miami Dade county, an angry mob of Republican operatives, organized through Congressman Tom DeLay's office in Washington, stormed the recount center at a critical juncture.
也许最令人不安的是有关共和党暴力的报道。佛罗里达州的民主党官员表示，他们受到了共和党抗议者的踢打、追赶和辱骂。在迈阿密-戴德县，一群愤怒的共和党特工，通过华盛顿汤姆·迪莱议员的办公室组织，在关键时刻冲进了重新计票中心。
New York Republican Congressman John Sweeney commanded the troops to shut it down, according to the Wall Street Journal . When the demonstrators later held a Thanksgiving Day party, George W. Bush and Dick Cheney called in and joked about the disruption. Again, there was no equivalent to this on the Democratic side.
据《华尔街日报》报道，纽约共和党众议员约翰·斯威尼（John Sweeney）指挥部队将其关闭。当示威者后来举办感恩节派对时，乔治·W·布什和迪克·切尼（Dick Cheney）打电话进来，并开玩笑地谈论了那次干扰。同样，民主党方面也没有与之对等的情况。
Now that the dust has settled, everyone seems to be proceeding as if none of this nastiness ever happened. I can't forget, even if I want to. Watching Bush take the oath of office as James Baker and the Supreme Court looked on, it was hard not to think of the ugliness that had got him to this point, and it's hard to believe that we've seen the last of it. George Bush ran as a different kind of Republican-- a uniter, not a divider, and certainly not a hater. Then came Florida.
现在尘埃落定，每个人似乎都在继续生活，就好像这一切令人不快的事情从未发生过一样。即使我想忘记，我也无法忘记。看着布什在詹姆斯·贝克和最高法院的注视下宣誓就职，很难不想到那些将他推向这一步的丑陋事件，而且很难相信我们已经看到了它的终结。乔治·布什以一种不同类型的共和党人身份竞选——一个团结者，而非分裂者，更绝对不是一个仇恨者。然后就发生了佛罗里达事件。
Last week I couldn't help notice a photograph in the New York Times of conservative strategists planning to support the nomination of John Ashcroft for Attorney General. And Ashcroft doesn't exactly fit anyone's notion of unity or inclusiveness. The meeting was being run by Grover Norquist, the Gingrich protege with a pet boa constrictor. I wondered if everything I had seen on the right in the '90s was just a prelude to what's about to happen.
上周，我不禁注意到《纽约时报》上的一张照片，保守派战略家正计划支持约翰·阿什克罗夫特（John Ashcroft）担任司法部长。阿什克罗夫特并不完全符合任何人对于团结或包容的概念。会议由格罗弗·诺奎斯特主持，那个养着宠物蟒蛇的金里奇门生。我怀疑我在90年代在右翼看到的一切，都只是即将发生之事的前奏。
David Brock. A version of this story appears in the issue of Talk Magazine , which is now on newsstands. Brock is writing a memoir of his years in the conservative movement and his break from it. It'll be out in the fall.
大卫·布洛克。这个故事的一个版本出现在目前在报摊上出售的《Talk》杂志上。布洛克正在撰写关于他多年来在保守派运动中以及与该运动决裂的回忆录。该书将于秋季出版。
Act Three, Bedroom Politics. When it comes to political fighting, there is no more intimate a space than a marriage, where you have to get along, where you have to figure out how to move on and get over disagreements. Scott Rayson is a corporate lawyer and his wife Carrie is a social worker which, you might think already is a recipe for political fighting right there. But in fact, they have always voted together in 10 years of marriage. They both supported Bill Clinton. And then something changed.
第三幕，“卧室政治”。说到政治斗争，没有比婚姻更亲密的空间了，在那里你需要和睦相处，需要弄清楚如何继续前进并克服分歧。斯科特·雷森（Scott Rayson）是一名公司律师，他的妻子嘉莉（Carrie）是一名社会工作者，你可能会认为这本身就是政治斗争的根源。但实际上，在十年的婚姻中，他们投票时总是保持一致。他们都支持比尔·克林顿。然后发生了一些变化。
At some point over the summer, I believe we were eating dinner one night, and Scott said, you know I think I'm going to vote for Bush. And the only other time in our marriage that I have been that caught off guard was years ago. We have three little boys. And when the second one was about a year old, I started lobbying for a third child. And I would swear we'd had that conversation, that if things went well, we would try and have three children.
在夏天的某个时候，我想我们有一天晚上在吃晚餐，斯科特说，你知道，我想我打算投票给布什。而在我们的婚姻中，我唯一一次感到如此措手不及是多年前。我们有三个小男孩。当第二个孩子大约一岁时，我开始游说要第三个孩子。我发誓我们讨论过，如果一切顺利，我们会尝试要三个孩子。
And finally one morning Scott sat down and took me by the shoulders and he said, I'm not sure you listen to me anymore. I'm not sure I want another baby. And it felt like the ground shifted under my feet. It was one of those marital moments where you think, oh, this could be a problem. And in the same way, he said it in the same way, he said, I'm not sure I want to have another baby. He said, I think I might vote for Bush.
最后一天早上，斯科特坐下来，抓住我的肩膀说，我不确定你是否还在听我说话。我不确定我是否想要另一个孩子。这感觉就像脚下的地面移位了。这是那种婚姻中的时刻之一，你会想，哦，这可能是一个问题。而且他以同样的方式，以同样的方式说了出来，他说，我不确定我是否想再要一个孩子。他说，我想我可能会投票给布什。
Was it one of these moments where you just felt like, do I know you?
这是那种让你觉得“我认识你吗？”的时刻之一吗？
Oh, sure.
噢，当然。
I think we watched Al Gore's speech, his acceptance speech, and our reactions to it were very different. And that's the first time it became obvious that TV was going to be a problem for us.
我想我们看了阿尔·戈尔的演讲，他的接受提名演讲，我们的反应截然不同。这是第一次变得显而易见，电视将成为我们的问题。
So as election season unfolded, would you watch, for example, the debates together?
那么随着选举季节的展开，例如，你们会一起看辩论吗？
We weren't able to do that. We watched them in separate rooms.
我们没能做到。我们在不同的房间看的。
So what room were you in and what room was he in?
那你待在哪个房间，他待在哪个房间？
Usually I sent him down to the-- there's an old TV. We have two televisions in our house. There's a television that's down in a sub-basement that the children use as a playroom.
通常我把他打发到……家里有两个电视。有一个电视在地下室，孩子们把它当作游戏室。
So you would banish him to the sub-basement?
所以你会把他流放到地下室？
He was banished.
他被流放了。
Yeah, I mean there was-- maybe a self-imposed exile is a better way to put it. And I'd go down in our playroom and watch and she'd be in the kitchen watching. And you could hear the two of us talking at the TV at just the opposite times saying just the opposite things.
是的，我是说——也许自我放逐是一个更好的说法。我会待在游戏室里看，而她会在厨房里看。你可以听到我们俩在完全相反的时间对着电视说话，说着完全相反的话。
Were there moments between you when there was just an air of tension because of politics?
在你们之间有没有过因为政治而充满紧张气氛的时刻？
Yeah, there were several times. When it really first dawned on me that we can't just accidentally be watching this coverage in separate rooms, was one night at dinner and she just slammed a plate down in front of me and she just said, so tell me why is it that you're going to vote for George Bush?
有，有过好几次。当我真正意识到我们不能只是偶然在不同房间看这些报道时，是在晚餐时，她只是把盘子重重地放在我面前，她说，那么告诉我，为什么你要投票给乔治·布什？
I was still struggling to make him change his mind. And I really did work very hard. And you see, I'd been successful in the past. So it was really hard for me to accept that I couldn't convince him, in some way, that what he was doing was wrong.
我当时还在努力让他改变主意。我确实非常努力。你看，我过去很成功。所以让我接受我无法说服他，无法让他意识到他所做的是错的，这真的很难。
My whole premise was well, the election will be over on the first Tuesday and we can get back to norm. And it didn't. It went on for another month.
我所有的前提是，好吧，选举将在第一个星期二结束，我们能恢复正常。但并没有。它又持续了一个月。
You know, in our life together, typically you meet a couple or you meet an individual. And typically, Scott and I will like that person or not be terribly impressed or interested in that person for the same reasons.
你知道，在我们在一起的生活中，通常你会遇到一对夫妇或一个人。通常，斯科特和我喜欢那个人，或者因为同样的原因对那个人印象不深或不感兴趣。
You kind of agree about people.
你们对人的看法比较一致。
We agree about people, we agree about so many things.
我们对人一致，我们对很多事情看法一致。
And somehow on this, you're not agreeing?
而不知何故，在这一点上，你们不一致了？
Right. For me, it generated a lot of anger with him. And I just didn't get it.
是的。对我来说，这对他产生了很多愤怒。我就是不理解。
And did it get such a rise of you because you felt like it wasn't Bush, per se, because it said something about Scott?
是因为你觉得这不是关于布什本身，而是因为它说明了斯科特的问题，所以你才如此激动吗？
Yes, oh yes.
是的，噢，是的。
And what did it say about Scott?
它说明了斯科特什么？
That he had kind of, in front of me somehow, become conservative and I wasn't aware of it.
说明他在我面前不知怎么变成了保守派，而我却没意识到。
And what does it mean to you to be conservative?
对你来说，作为保守派意味着什么？
Well, that's a good question. What it means to be conservative for me is that you look out for your best interests, first and foremost. And I don't believe that that's a good way to live. And I don't live that way.
嗯，这是个好问题。对我来说，作为保守派意味着你首先关心的是你自己的最大利益。我不认为这是一种好的生活方式。我也不那样生活。
I don't know the right word, really. I'd say I felt a little insulted by all of that. Why would she think that poorly of me, when she knows me as well as she does, over this candidate? And I just realized that I wasn't going to be able to talk to her. And that's when I just decided that it's really for the best to really just not talk about it.
我真的不知道确切的词。我会说我被这一切感到有点被侮辱了。为什么她会因为这个候选人而把我看得很低，明明她那么了解我？我意识到我没法和她谈这个。那就是我决定最好真的不要谈论它的原因。
Carrie, I understand at some point, your husband Scott got invited to the inauguration? Could you tell me the story of that, please?
嘉莉，据我了解，在某个时候，你丈夫斯科特收到了就职典礼的邀请？你能告诉我那个故事吗？
Well what happened was Scott made what I would consider a pretty hefty contribution to the Republican party. And what we got immediately was the most outrageous mail. We got so much mail from the NRA. Really out-there mail from people about, you know, let's tar and feather Clinton. And I would just pile that up on the table every day and tell him he had more mail. So then he gets this great, huge envelope for the inauguration and all the parties and everything. and so I propped that up especially for him to see. But he would never have gone.
嗯，发生的事情是斯科特做了我认为对共和党来说相当大的一笔捐款。我们立刻收到了最令人发指的邮件。我们从全国步枪协会（NRA）收到了那么多邮件。真的是来自那些关于，你知道，“让我们把克林顿涂上柏油和羽毛”这类人的极端邮件。我每天都会把它堆在桌子上，告诉他还有更多邮件。所以后来他收到了这个参加就职典礼及所有派对的大信封。我特意把它撑起来让他看。但他本来就不会去。
Really? He didn't have any interest in going at all?
真的吗？他一点去的兴趣都没有？
No. He's not political that way. He's not involved in politics that way.
没有。他不是那种政治化的人。他没有以那种方式参与政治。
Well, I would love to have done it. I had my little inaugural invitation and was gleefully reviewing it. And she just found it disgusting. So I didn't even suggest the possibility of going.
嗯，我本来会很乐意去的。我拿到了我的小就职典礼邀请函，兴高采烈地看着它。而她只是觉得这很恶心。所以我甚至没有提可能去参加的可能性。
So you didn't even try to talk your wife into this?
所以你甚至没有试着说服你妻子去参加？
Oh no, wouldn't even have dreamed of it. Not a chance.
噢，不，甚至没想过。没机会。
Does she know that you might have wanted to go at all?
她知道你可能想去吗？
No. I mean, I didn't say anything about it.
不知道。我的意思是，我什么都没说。
It seems like the two of you have the kind of marriage where you haven't had an issue before where you just put it aside and said, OK, we're not going to talk about this anymore. And now you have one. Your first one.
看起来你们俩的婚姻在以前没有出现过这种情况，即你们把它放在一边说，好吧，我们不再谈论这个了。而现在你们有了。第一次出现。
Well, yeah. That's right. And I guess if you're going to have one, it's not a bad one to have.
嗯，是的。没错。我猜如果非得有一次，这也不是什么坏事。
From the outside, we hear about these marriages, people with differing political views-- The Mary Matalin, James Carville marriages-- and it all sounds so lovable and cute.
从外部看，我们听说这些婚姻，有着不同政治观点的人——玛丽·马塔林（Mary Matalin）和詹姆斯·卡维尔（James Carville）的婚姻——听起来都很可爱和迷人。
No, I don't think it's been cute. And I don't think I've been very lovable at all, and I haven't viewed him as being terribly lovable through all of this.
不，我不认为这很可爱。我不认为我一直很迷人，在这一切中我也没有认为他很迷人。
Well, I've seen Matalin and Carville plenty of times together on television and, I don't know if you ever saw them together during the aftermath of the election, but it looked awful. I'd never seen Carville so quiet. She just looked hostile at him.
嗯，我在电视上见过马塔林和卡维尔很多次，我不知道你有没有在选举结束后见过他们在一起，但看起来太糟糕了。我从未见过卡维尔这么安静。她看着他时充满了敌意。
Are you worried about these next four years together with Bush in the White House?
你担心未来四年布什入主白宫的日子吗？
No.
不。
Between the two of us? No. Because we really do-- we work through things.
我们俩之间？不。因为我们确实——我们能解决问题。
(SUBJECT) SCOTT RAYSON: I am dreading the next election. I think the midterms are going to be bad enough. But four years from now, I think it's going to be several months of being banished to the playroom. I'll have to get involved in some big deal that takes me to Botswana or something so I just go off and work for a couple months.
（受访者）斯科特·雷森：我正在为下一次选举感到恐惧。我认为中期选举就已经够糟糕了。但四年后，我想这又会是几个月的“被流放到游戏室”。我得去参与某个把我带到博茨瓦纳什么的重大交易，好让我走开工作几个月。
Scott and Carrie Rayson, in Nashville, Tennessee. Coming up, a love supreme, a hate supreme, we go back once more, slowly, to a certain five-to-four court decision. And this time, we really, really, really use our brains. In a minute, for Public Radio International when our program continues.
斯科特和嘉莉·雷森，在田纳西州纳什维尔。接下来，“至高无上的爱”，或者是“至高无上的恨”，我们再一次慢慢回到那个五比四的法院裁决。这一次，我们要真正地、真正地、真正地用我们的大脑。稍后，在我们的节目继续时，为国际公共广播电台呈现。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today, one week into the Bush presidency, we bring you stories of people trying to move on after our bitter national election recount imbroglio. I don't even know what that word means, but I feel like this is my one chance to say it.
这是《这就是美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种各样的故事。今天，在布什总统任期的第一周，我们为您带来人们在痛苦的全国选举重新计票风波后试图继续生活的故事。我甚至不知道那个词意味着什么，但我感觉这是我唯一的机会说出它。
We've arrived Act Four of our program. Act Four, Let's Reason Together. When the Supreme Court handed down the decision that ended the election, it came and went in a day. There was a flurry of commentary, some of it from people who are usually very evenhanded and calm about the court, like Jeffrey Rosen, who appears on ABC News and on NPR sometimes, who teaches law at George Washington University Law School. He was saying things like--
我们来到了节目的第四幕。第四幕，“让我们共同论证”。当最高法院做出结束选举的裁决时，它来来去去只有一天。评论如潮，其中一些来自通常对法院非常公平和冷静的人，比如杰弗里·罗森（Jeffrey Rosen），他有时出现在ABC新闻和NPR上，他在乔治华盛顿大学法学院教授法律。他当时说——
I don't want to be hyperbolic, but it's safe to say that this is the most outrageous decision that those of us who consider ourselves moderate in the legal academy have ever seen. The most temperate scholars are literally at a loss for words to try to explain this decision, which was so ill-reasoned that it's impossible to view it as anything but political.
我不想夸大其词，但可以说这是我们在法律学术界自视为温和派的人所见过的最令人愤慨的裁决。最温和的学者们简直无法用言语来解释这个决定，因为它论证得如此拙劣，以至于除了政治动机之外，不可能有其他解释。
Was it really this bad? If so, there was a feeling among those of us who put this radio show together, that we wanted to understand exactly what was wrong with this decision. And more than that, we wanted to believe that there is a reasonable case to be made for the decision. Thinking anything else is just too harsh.
它真的有那么糟糕吗？如果是这样，我们这些制作这个广播节目的人有一种感觉，我们想确切地理解这个决定出了什么问题。更重要的是，我们想相信这个决定背后有一个合理的理由。想到其他任何事情都太严厉了。
So with some distance on the decision and some time, we assembled four constitutional experts-- two for and two against the decision-- to explain it. We figured if we had these lingering questions about the whole thing, a lot of people probably did. Here's what we learned. There are really just two parts to the decision. The majority first says that the recount in Florida was violating principles of basic fairness under the equal protection clause of the constitution. Then it sets out a remedy to fix that. We'll take these one at a time. First, the equal protection Argument Here's Mike McConnell, one of the leading conservative Constitutional experts in the country.
因此，在裁决过去一段时间并留出一些距离后，我们召集了四位宪法专家——两位支持、两位反对该裁决——来解释它。我们想，如果我们对整件事还有这些悬而未决的问题，很多人可能也会有。这是我们学到的。决定实际上只有两部分。多数方首先表示，佛罗里达州的重新计票违反了宪法平等保护条款下的基本公平原则。然后它提出了一个补救措施来修复它。我们一次处理一个。首先，平等保护论点。这里是迈克·麦康奈尔（Mike McConnell），全国领先的保守派宪法专家之一。
The argument is really quite simple and common sensical, which is if there's to be a statewide recount, it has to be done on fair and equal terms with some kind of an objective standard for deciding what counts as a vote.
论点其实非常简单且合乎常理，那就是如果要进行全州范围的重新计票，它必须在公平平等的条件下进行，并且要有某种客观标准来确定什么是选票。
The Supreme Court goes into great detail about all the unfairness in the way that the Florida Supreme Court was allowing the recount to happen. The unfairnesses include which votes got recounted and which didn't, whether the people doing the recounting were properly trained and fair, whether there was a fair way to challenge a result. Some counties counted dimpled chads one way, some counted them another way. Palm Beach County switched standards. There  were reports that different teams within a county sometimes used different standards.
最高法院详细说明了佛罗里达最高法院允许重新计票方式中的所有不公平之处。这些不公平之处包括哪些选票被重新计票而哪些没有，执行重新计票的人是否受过适当培训且公平，以及是否有公平的方式来挑战结果。一些县以一种方式统计凹陷戳孔，另一些县以另一种方式统计。棕榈滩县改变了标准。有报道称，同一个县内的不同团队有时使用不同的标准。
The Florida Supreme Court's decision was a mishmash of standards, which almost made it impossible that there could be a fair count in Florida.
佛罗里达最高法院的裁决是标准的混杂，这几乎使得佛罗里达州不可能进行公平的统计。
In fact, even people who have big problems with the Supreme Court decision agree that there are all sorts of unfairnesses built into what the Florida court did. The question is whether these unfairnesses are so bad that one could conclude that the Florida court had actually left the realm of normal judicial interpretation, leaving aside Florida law entirely, leaving aside impartiality, and committing what the Supreme Court calls, scarily, a non-judicial act. Only then can the US Supreme Court intervene.
事实上，即使是对最高法院裁决有很大意见的人也同意，佛罗里达法院所做的事情中内置了各种各样的不公平。问题在于这些不公平是否严重到足以断定佛罗里达法院实际上已经离开了正常司法解释的领域，完全抛开了佛罗里达法律，抛开了公正性，并犯下了最高法院所称的、可怕的“非司法行为”。只有这样，美国最高法院才能介入。
I was not a fan of the Florida Supreme Court's decision.
我不是佛罗里达最高法院裁决的支持者。
Again, Jeffrey Rosen.
再次引用杰弗里·罗森。
The justices had gone too far in changing the counting standards and imposing a new deadline. But even people like me, who have questions about the Florida Supreme Court, can't claim that it was lawless beyond the realm of reasonable debate. It was based on a series of judicial precedents in Florida, going back to the early 20th century.
法官们在改变计票标准和强加新期限方面做得太过火了。但即使是像我这样对佛罗里达最高法院有疑问的人，也不能声称它是超出合理辩论范围的无法无天。它基于佛罗里达州一系列可追溯到20世纪初的司法先例。
In contrast, says Rosen, the Supreme Court's decision cites a few precedents. But they either do not support the case or, sometimes, precedents seem to go against the decision in Bush versus Gore. For instance, in the past conservatives on the court have said that you have to prove that discrimination is intentional before it is a real violation of the equal protection clause.
相比之下，罗森说，最高法院的裁决引用了一些先例。但它们要么不支持该案件，要么有时，先例似乎与布什诉戈尔案的裁决相矛盾。例如，过去法院的保守派人士曾表示，在它成为平等保护条款的真正违规行为之前，你必须证明歧视是有意的。
Indeed, in the affirmative action and civil rights cases and the voting rights cases too, they'd gone to great lengths to stress that voting systems that had the inadvertent effect of diluting the voting strength of African American voters but were not intended to disadvantage African Americans are not Constitutional violations. The conservatives told us again and again, in cases like the Mobile case, that you need intentional discrimination. No one is claiming here that the different counting standards-- whether imposed by the court or by the Florida legislature-- constitute intentional discrimination. I try to run through each method of interpretation. I'm literally at a loss to defend this decision.
事实上，在平权法案、民权案件和投票权案件中，他们都竭尽全力强调，那些无意中稀释了非裔美国选民投票权但无意让非裔美国人处于劣势的投票系统，并不是宪法违规。保守派在诸如Mobile案等案件中一次又一次地告诉我们，你需要有意的歧视。这里没有人声称不同的计票标准——无论是法院还是佛罗里达立法机构强加的——构成有意的歧视。我试着过一遍每种解释方法。我简直无法为这个决定辩护。
Even legal experts who support this Supreme Court decision agree that the precedents cited by the majority don't really say much that backs up the decision. Again, here's Mike McConnell.
即使支持最高法院这一裁决的法律专家也同意，多数方引用的先例并没有真正说明支持该裁决的内容。再次，这里是迈克·麦康奈尔。
I don't think that this case is decided on the basis of precedence. I think it was decided on the basis of a pretty common sensical understanding of fairness. That when you're going to have a statewide recount in a single jurisdiction, that they have to count all the votes the same way. Here's Greg Sisk from Drake Law School, another supporter of the decision.
我认为这个案件不是基于先例决定的。我认为它是基于一种相当合乎常理的公平理解而决定的。那就是当你要在单个司法管辖区内进行全州范围的重新计票时，他们必须以同样的方式计算所有选票。这里是德雷克法学院的格雷格·西斯克（Greg Sisk），该裁决的另一位支持者。
In my view, if most people actually read this 12-page decision and looked at the listing of the problems with the unfairness of the approach that the Florida Supreme Court had set up, that we would reach a consensus-- yeah, that's not a very good way to do things. And the only thing that we'd be left to decide is, is it unconstitutional, then, to do it that way?
在我看来，如果大多数人真正读过这个12页的裁决，并审视了佛罗里达最高法院设立的方法中所存在的不公平问题，我们会达成共识——是的，那不是处理事情的好方法。而我们要决定的唯一一件事是，那么以这种方式处理是否违宪？
In the end, there is simply a great divide between the people who support this decision and those who impose it. And at one level, the divide is not over the reasoning in the decision. The divide is over whether or not they see the Florida court's recount as being profoundly flawed and deeply unfair. If they do, then they conclude that there was enough of a problem to justify the very unusual step of the Supreme Court jumping in.
最终，支持该裁决的人与反对该裁决的人之间存在巨大的分歧。在某种程度上，这种分歧不是关于决定中的推理。这种分歧在于他们是否认为佛罗里达法院的重新计票存在深层缺陷和极度不公平。如果他们认为是，那么他们得出结论，有足够的问题来证明最高法院介入这一非常不寻常的步骤是合理的。
If they don't, then the logic of the decision dissolves. This comes up over and over when you talk to the two sides. Take two of the arguments against the decision that you've probably heard on the news at some point.
如果他们不认为，那么这个决定的逻辑就会瓦解。当你与双方交谈时，这一点会反复出现。以你在新闻中可能听到的两个反对该裁决的论点为例。
Critics said that it was grotesque for the Supreme Court to stop the Florida recount on equal protection grounds when the point of the recount was to give equal protection to the unfortunate voters who lived in districts with inferior, less-reliable voting equipment-- the punch card ballots.
批评者说，最高法院以平等保护为由停止佛罗里达州的重新计票是荒谬的，因为重新计票的目的正是为了给予居住在拥有劣质、可靠性较低投票设备（打孔卡选票）地区的不幸选民平等的保护。
Critics also said that the US Supreme Court put the Florida court into a kind of Catch-22 situation. Here's how this works. The Supreme Court first told Florida to be careful, not to change the rules of the election after election day. Don't go in, don't muck around with the law, that would be unconstitutional. So the Florida court refused to set a statewide standard for counting ballots because that might be seen as altering the law. Then the Supreme Court spun around and overturned them, saying no, you should have imposed a statewide standard in the interest of fairness.
批评者还说，美国最高法院将佛罗里达法院置于了一种“第22条军规”（Catch-22）的境地。它是这样运作的。最高法院首先告诉佛罗里达州要小心，不要在选举日之后改变选举规则。不要介入，不要弄乱法律，那是违宪的。所以佛罗里达法院拒绝设定全州范围的计票标准，因为那可能被视为修改法律。然后最高法院转过身推翻了他们，说不，为了公平起见，你应该强加一个全州标准。
Faced with both of these criticisms, supporters of the equal protection argument are unmoved. Because, again, in their view the bottom line is that there were just grave problems with the Florida recount that the Florida court needed to fix.
面对这些批评，平等保护论点的支持者们不为所动。因为同样，在他们看来，底线是佛罗里达州的重新计票存在严重的需要修复的问题。
If, on election day, some voters faced worse voting equipment than others, well this recount scheme-- in their view, impossibly biased towards the Democrats in a few select areas that had been hand-picked by Gore, this scheme would not make things any fairer. And if the Florida election law was so vague that it was impossible to invent a fair, statewide standard for a recount without changing the law, then it's better to just shut down the recount. And what's the loss? After all, recounting in a biased way is no better than not recounting at all. Again, Mike McConnell.
如果在选举日，一些选民面临的投票设备比其他人更差，那么这个重新计票方案——在他们看来，以戈尔精选出的几个地区对民主党人不可救药地偏向——这个方案不会让事情变得更公平。如果佛罗里达的选举法如此模糊，以至于不可能在不修改法律的情况下发明一个公平的全州重新计票标准，那么最好停止重新计票。损失是什么？毕竟，以偏向的方式重新计票并不比不重新计票更好。再次，迈克·麦康奈尔。
There was good reason not to order a recount at all. But if there was to be recount, it ought to be a fair recount. For the Florida court to order a recount that was systematically rigged in favor of one candidate was just unjustifiable.
完全不进行重新计票有充分的理由。但如果要进行重新计票，那应该是公平的重新计票。佛罗里达法院下令进行那种系统性地偏向某一候选人的重新计票是完全无法辩解的。
Let's move on to the second part of the Supreme Court decision. Once the Supreme Court decided that the Florida recount violated the equal protection amendment of the Constitution, what should they do about it? Conservative legal scholar Mike McConnell says that he agrees with the court when it comes to the equal protection part of their decision. But that's it.
让我们转到最高法院裁决的第二部分。一旦最高法院裁定佛罗里达州的重新计票违反了宪法平等保护修正案，他们应该怎么做？保守派法律学者迈克·麦康奈尔说，他同意法院关于其裁决的平等保护部分。但仅此而已。
The weakness in the opinion has to do with the issue of remedy-- that if the problem with the Florida Supreme Court's decision is that in order to recount under unfair, unequal, arbitrary chaotic standards, the proper remedy would have been to send it back to the Florida court to conduct the recount under fair, consistent practical standards. It would have been better for the US Supreme Court to leave it up to the state to do that.
意见中的弱点与补救措施的问题有关——如果佛罗里达最高法院裁决的问题在于，为了在不公平、不平等、任意混乱的标准下进行重新计票，适当的补救措施应该是将其送回佛罗里达法院，在公平、一致、实际的标准下进行重新计票。由美国最高法院将其留给州政府来做会更好。
Normally when people are being treated unequally, the way you treat them equally is you raise everybody up to the fair level.
通常，当人们受到不平等待遇时，平等对待他们的方式是将每个人都提升到公平的水平。
Liberal legal expert, Pam Karlan of Stanford Law School.
自由派法律专家，斯坦福法学院的帕姆·卡兰（Pam Karlan）。
So if these ballots were going to be counted in Broward, then you'd count them in Palm Beach. And instead, what the Supreme Court said was in order to solve the potential inequality, don't count any of these people's votes, even though there are large numbers of ballots that weren't counted the first time around on which it's absolutely clear what the voter's intent was. And the Supreme Court stopped that process, leaving a lot of voters as disenfranchised as if they'd never gone to the polls in the first place.
所以如果这些选票要在布劳沃德县清点，那么你也会在棕榈滩县清点。而相反，最高法院所说的是，为了解决潜在的不平等，不要清点任何人的选票，尽管有大量的选票在第一次清点时没有被计算在内，而选民的意图是绝对明确的。最高法院停止了那个过程，让许多选民被剥夺了公民权，就好像他们从未去过投票站一样。
The Supreme Court, of course, stopped the Florida recount on December 9 and then handed down its opinion on the 12. The opinion said that because there wasn't enough time at that point to do a fair recount, they would call it a day. The state would go to George Bush. In his dissent, Justice Breyer points out that the majority decided that there was no time for a recount without any evidence on the court record that the recount could not have been completed on time, by December 18, which is when the electoral college would meet. Breyer writes, quote, "the majority finds facts outside of the record on matters that state courts are in a far better position to address," end quote.
最高法院当然在12月9日停止了佛罗里达州的重新计票，然后在12日发布了意见。意见称，因为当时没有足够的时间进行公平的重新计票，他们决定结束。该州将归属于乔治·布什。在异议中，布雷耶法官（Justice Breyer）指出，多数方在法庭记录中没有任何证据表明重新计票无法在12月18日选举人团会议之前完成的情况下，裁定没有时间进行重新计票。布雷耶写道，引用：“多数方在州法院处于更好位置处理的事项上，在记录之外发现了事实”，引用结束。
So what was the majority's argument for declaring it over on December 12? Well the majority doesn't say much about it at all. Except that December 12 was the date that the Florida court was shooting for as the deadline for finishing the vote. Greg Sisk thinks that this was not only reasonable, he says it was the most sensible way to do it.
那么多数方宣布它在12月12日结束的论点是什么？嗯，多数方对此并没有说太多。除了12月12日是佛罗里达法院设定的完成投票截止日期之外。格雷格·西斯克认为这不仅合理，他说这是最明智的做法。
First of all, the Florida Supreme Court had been saying all along, since their initial decision, had always been operating on the assumption that December 12 was the deadline. And the reason they reached that conclusion, the Florida Supreme Court did, was this. There's a federal statute that provides that if you, as a state, want to appoint electors in a way that they're not subject to challenge by Congress as having been improperly selected, you have to make your selection by December 12. And the Florida Supreme Court had assumed all along that the legislature, of course, would have wanted Florida to take advantage of that safe harbor provision.
首先，佛罗里达最高法院自初步裁决以来一直说，一直在以12月12日为最后期限的前提下运作。而佛罗里达最高法院得出这一结论的原因是这个。有一项联邦法规规定，如果你作为一个州想要任命选举人，而这些选举人不会受到国会关于任命不当的质疑，你就必须在12月12日之前做出选择。而佛罗里达最高法院一直假设，立法机构当然会希望佛罗里达利用该“安全港”条款。
Dissenters point out that the December 12 date is an arbitrary one, and not part of Florida state law. If states miss the safe harbor deadline, they can still get their votes in. Pam Karlan.
持不同意见者指出，12月12日是一个任意的日期，而不是佛罗里达州法律的一部分。如果各州错过了安全港截止日期，他们仍然可以提交他们的选票。帕姆·卡兰。
Obviously, if you can get it done by December 12, that's the best. But it's hard to say that Florida would prefer an inaccurate count on December 12 to a more accurate count on the 15 or the 18. Or in a case like Hawaii in 1960, they didn't get their votes in until early January.
显然，如果你能在12月12日之前完成，那是最好的。但很难说佛罗里达州会更喜欢12月12日不准确的统计，而不是15日或18日更准确的统计。或者像1960年的夏威夷，直到一月初才提交选票。
Professor Sisk, I have to say after speaking with four different scholars about this decision, I sort of despair that people will see eye to eye on this.
西斯克教授，我必须说，在与四位不同的学者讨论了这个决定后，我有一种绝望感，人们会对这个问题看法一致。
I know, I think that's probably right. I think this is one of those cases that often one goes out the same door you came in.
我知道，我想那可能是对的。我认为这是那些常常从哪扇门进去就从哪扇门出来的案件之一。
I wonder if the very best thing to come out of a discussion like this is that people on each side will understand that the other side has a reasonable argument and might vilify each other a little less. People are so mad at each other.
我想知道这样的讨论产生出的最好的结果是否是，每一方的人都会理解另一方有合理的论点，并减少一点对彼此的诋毁。人们对彼此太生气了。
Well, this was one of those things are brought out some of the worst in terms of partisanship. One cannot imagine a more disastrous way to end an election campaign. People were more passionate in favor of their candidate after the election than they were beforehand.
嗯，这是带出党派偏见最糟糕的事情之一。人们无法想象还有什么比这更灾难性的方式来结束一场选举运动。选举后人们支持候选人的热情比选举前还要高。
That is so true.
真是这样。
Do these discussions convince anybody of anything? Speaking completely honestly, I came to this as a Gore-leaning voter, wanting to be persuaded by the majority on the Supreme Court. And in all honesty, I have to say, I did not find their arguments convincing. But I can say now that I see why they think they're convincing. Maybe that's something.
这些讨论能让任何人信服什么吗？完全诚实地说，我作为一名倾向于戈尔的选民来到这里，想要被最高法院的多数派说服。老实说，我必须说，我没有发现他们的论点令人信服。但我现在可以说，我看到了为什么他们认为自己令人信服。也许那也算一点东西吧。
Act Five, What Would You Know Who Do? Richard Harris, a Reverend from Belgrade, Florida says he doesn't even know how many days and weeks he spent registering voters for this fall's election.
第五幕，“你猜是谁会怎么做？”理查德·哈里斯（Richard Harris），来自佛罗里达州贝尔格莱德的一位牧师说，他甚至不知道自己花了多少天和几周时间在今年秋天的选举中为选民登记。
Oh god, to be honest with you, I stopped counting long ago. But we started out, actually, about a year ago. We reached out through churches, reached out through civic groups, fraternities, sororities. And we actually got out and beat the bushes. We went down where I live--
噢，上帝，老实说，我很久以前就停止计数了。但实际上我们是在大约一年前开始的。我们通过教堂、公民团体、兄弟会、姐妹会进行接触。我们实际上出去挨家挨户拜访。我们去了我住的地方——
When you were saying that, I was picturing guys fishing and you all just walking up to them.
当你那样说时，我脑海中浮现出渔夫们，而你们全都径直走过去。
That too, and believe it or not, we did that. We have a marina and a pier in our community. And we did that, too. Oh yeah, we went up on the pier and we actually did that. As a matter of fact, if we happened to be going somewhere and someone was fishing off one of the canals and bridges there, we actually stop, hey, you a registered voter? They'd give us a thumbs up. We'd slow down, give us the thumbs up sign. I mean when we were in the supermarket. It became such a part of us. When we're in the supermarket or in line at the bank, or whatever. If you saw someone, we'd register them right on the spot.
这也是，信不信由你，我们确实做了。我们的社区有一个码头和一个堤岸。我们也做了那个。噢，是的，我们走上堤岸，我们确实做了。事实上，如果我们恰好要到什么地方去，而有人在运河和桥梁上钓鱼，我们实际上会停下来，“嘿，你是登记选民吗？”他们会给我们竖起大拇指。我们会减速，竖起大拇指。我的意思是当我们在超市时。它成了我们的一部分。当我们在超市或者在银行排队，或者其他什么地方时。如果你看到某人，我们就会当场给他们登记。
Do you have a count of the number of people you all registered?
你们登记的总人数有记录吗？
Personally, maybe around 1,200 or so. And I'm sure it was more than that because I stopped counting at one point.
就我个人而言，大约1200人左右。我肯定不止这些，因为我在某一点停止计数了。
You personally registered 1,200 people?
你个人登记了1200人？
Oh yeah, definitely.
噢，是的，绝对是。
Come election day, the number of African Americans who voted in Florida broke all records. It rose 50% over the last presidential race. But over the course of the day, Reverend Harris witnessed some of the problems at the polls, which have led to civil rights hearings. He saw police at a polling place asking voters for ID. He saw polling officials from poorer districts unable to get through to state officials to confirm voter IDs. There were people who were thrown off the voter roles because of a faulty list that the state of Florida bought, which incorrectly identified over 8,000 people as felons, who aren't allowed to cast ballots, according to Florida law.
选举日到了，在佛罗里达州投票的非裔美国人数量打破了所有记录。它比上次总统选举上升了50%。但在一天的时间里，哈里斯牧师目睹了投票站出现的一些问题，这导致了民权听证会。他看到投票站的警察要求选民提供身份证。他看到来自贫困地区的投票官员无法联系州官员确认选民身份。由于佛罗里达州购买的一份错误名单，有些选民被从选民名单中剔除，这份名单错误地将超过8,000人识别为重罪犯，根据佛罗里达州法律，他们不允许投票。
You could feel it. Certainly by 3 or 4 o'clock in the afternoon, you could really feel that there was something definitely wrong. It had gone wrong and you could just feel it. And by the time the polls had closed, there was just this uneasy feeling when I left to go home to watch the results. Something you can't put your hand on at the time, that's how I felt. Something is not right, it's just not right.
你可以感觉到它。当然到下午3点或4点，你就能真切地感觉到肯定出了什么问题。它出错了，你就能感觉到。当投票站关闭时，当我离开回家看结果时，有一种不安的感觉。那是当时你无法掌控的事情，这就是我的感受。有什么不对劲，就是不对劲。
Can I ask you honestly? As somebody who's trying to stay positive about this entire experience, did you have moments, as a man watching the election results and what happened in the weeks after, where you felt yourself just getting angrier and angrier at the Republicans? And angry, perhaps, in a way that you didn't feel entirely comfortable with as a man of God?
我可以诚实地问你吗？作为一个试图对整个经历保持积极态度的人，作为一个看着选举结果以及随后的几周里发生的事情的男人，你是否有过感到自己对共和党人越来越愤怒的时刻？而且这种愤怒，也许让你作为一个上帝的子民感到不太自在？
Actually, what I really felt was a questioning of my spirituality, to be honest with you. How can I sit back and just let this go like this? How can I accept these people as decent and human when I'm looking at them and I'm beginning to see-- tell you what bothers me. I listened to this on the testimony on the Ashcroft confirmation on my way up here to Atlanta.
事实上，老实说，我真正感觉到的是对自己信仰的质疑。我怎么能坐视不管，任由它这样发生呢？当我看着这些人时，我怎么能接受他们是体面和人性化的，我开始看到——告诉你什么困扰我。我在来亚特兰大的路上听了阿什克罗夫特确认听证会的证词。
That's what bothers me. When you try to ram Ashcroft down our throats, knowing he's controversial, knowing there's a great majority in this country, the public, who does not want him to be there, who is really frightened by the possibility that he will be confirmed. Then it says to me if you're going to be a president of compassion, as you have identified yourself-- you can't just say, I'm a compassionate president and then you've got your staff who's not. That's not going to work.
这就是困扰我的地方。当你试图把阿什克罗夫特硬塞给我们时，明知他是引起争议的，明知在这个国家有绝大多数公众不希望他出现在那里，那些对被确认的可能性感到真正恐惧的人。那么这对我来说，如果你要成为一个富有同情心的总统，正如你所自我标榜的那样——你不能只是说，“我是个富有同情心的总统”，然后你的员工却不是。那是行不通的。
I have a friend who watched Bush become president, and she wanted Gore to become, and saw the way it had happened. And she was remembering how, in 1992, I think it was, Dick Armey, Republican, stood up on Capitol Hill and referred to Clinton as "Your president." And she said she just doesn't want to become that. She just doesn't want to hate. And she says it's hard not to.
我有一个朋友，她看着布什成为总统，而她希望戈尔当选，并看到了所发生的事情。她记得1992年，我想是迪克·阿米（Dick Armey），那个共和党人，站在国会山上，称克林顿为“你们的总统”。她说她只是不想变成那样。她只是不想仇恨。她说这很难不去做。
I tell you what, she's absolutely right. I was at a basketball game last night at a college. And I'm going to be totally honest with you, when the National Anthem was playing, I sat down. I didn't get up. I couldn't. Something just held me down. It was very interesting and coincidental that the flag was directly-- there was a Confederate flag on one side, the state of Georgia flag on one side off to my left a little bit, but directly over my head was an American flag. So everybody in the gym turned around and looked. And I'm sitting right  up under the flag, not moving. But something was-- I just couldn't get up.
我告诉你，她是绝对正确的。昨晚我在一所大学看篮球比赛。我要完全诚实，当国歌响起时，我坐了下来。我没有站起来。我不能。有什么东西把我压住了。很有趣也很巧合的是，旗帜直接——我左边一点有一面邦联旗，左边一点有一面乔治亚州旗，但直接在我头上的是一面美国旗。所以体育馆里的每个人都转过身去看。我坐在旗帜下，一动不动。但有什么东西——我就是没法站起来。
And what was that something?
那个“什么东西”是什么？
To be honest with you, the only other time I felt like this was when I was beaten-- in segregation, the colored and white water fountain. And I stopped for a long time. Because what that flag symbolized for me at that particular point in time, this was not my country. And with no real rights. And that's the feeling that I'm getting now, that we have no real worth in their eyes.
老实说，我唯一一次有这种感觉是当我被殴打时——在隔离期间，“有色人种”和“白人”饮水机。我停了很长一段时间。因为那面旗帜在那一特定的时刻对我象征着什么，这不是我的国家。并且没有真正的权利。这就是我现在得到的感受，即在他们眼中我们没有真正的价值。
And that's what bothers me. And I have to pray real hard and ask God for forgiveness, not to dislike to the point where it turns into hatred of other people who were diametrically opposed to what's right. I figure what's right, anyway. And some of the sinister things they did, I have to forgive them. I have to. I have no choice. I have to forgive them so we can move on and the healing can start.
这就是困扰我的地方。我必须非常认真地祈祷并请求上帝原谅，不要讨厌到变成对那些与正确立场截然相反的人的仇恨。我反正想弄清楚什么是正确的。而且他们做的一些阴险的事情，我必须原谅他们。我必须。我别无选择。我必须原谅他们，以便我们能够继续前进，治愈才能开始。
And how's that going?
那进展如何？
I'm almost at the point where I'm sick and tired of being sick and tired. You remember that?
我几乎到了厌倦了这种厌倦的地步。你还记得吗？
Sure.
当然。
That's where I am right now. If you want to know what my secret prayer is-- my secret prayer is no longer a secret once I tell you this-- is that President-Elect Bush will have a change of heart and will see that he has been given an opportunity to mend a lot of fences, to make a real difference, that he can really change some things in this country for the better. And really prove to people and say, I just did that to get elected. And then really go ahead and do something for the good of the country. That's my prayer. That's my prayer.
我现在就是那种状态。如果你想知道我的秘密祈祷是什么——一旦我告诉你，我的秘密祈祷就不再是秘密了——那就是当选总统布什能改变主意，并看到他被赋予了一个修补很多裂痕、做出真正改变的机会，他真的能让这个国家的一些事情变得更好。并真正向人们证明并说，我只是为了当选才那样做的。然后真正去做一些为了国家利益的事情。这就是我的祈祷。这是我的祈祷。
Reverend Richard Harris.
理查德·哈里斯牧师。
Our program was produced today by Starlee Kine and myself, with Blue Chevigny, Jonathan Goldstein, Julie Snyder and Alex Blumberg. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Erin Yanke, our production trainee. This is her last show with us. Erin, we are sorry to see you go. Musical help from John Connors and Chris Lygan.
我们今天的节目由斯塔莉·凯恩（Starlee Kine）和我制作，蓝·切维尼（Blue Chevigny）、乔纳森·戈德斯坦（Jonathan Goldstein）、朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）和亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）共同制作。感谢我们的制作实习生托德·巴赫曼（Todd Bachmann）和艾琳·扬克（Erin Yanke）提供的制作帮助。这是她跟我们合作的最后一场节目。艾琳，我们很遗憾看到你离开。感谢约翰·康纳斯（John Connors）和克里斯·里根（Chris Lygan）提供的音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《这就是美国生活》由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who says regardless of party affiliation--
WBEZ管理层监管由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责，他说无论党派背景如何——
There's a really creepy side to you. There is, I'm sorry.
你确实有令人毛骨悚然的一面。真的有，我很抱歉。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《这就是美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。